joining me now florida congressman byron
donalds who serves on the house budget
committee and horace cooper project 21
co-chair great to see you both in studio
congressman um he voted against this 40
billion dollar uh spenderama um
the american people i think are really
scratching their heads on this
what's going on up there
that's a good question because even i
don't know listen we did 33 billion
dollars two weeks ago for ukraine
funding with military equipment that was
two weeks ago we come back to town this
week and there's a 40 million dollar
bill that we have literally two to three
hours to 40 million that just came out
of nowhere i wish it was 40 million 40
billion you're right 40 billion my
apologies that's how upset i am so
you're looking at this bill you're still
trying to figure out what's in it at
that point i'm like i'm voting no who
read it congressman hardly anybody read
it maybe the staff did but the members
didn't really opportunity your guess is
as good as mine it came out of nancy
pelosi's office in the white house so
lobbyists i imagine defense contractors
maybe food distribution company i don't
know but
the american people horus
are seeing our country grow weaker and
our families grow poorer day after day
yet apparently money does grow on trees
my mother used to say it doesn't grow
apparently it does grow on trees and
we're just you know going to send it you
know willy nilly with literally
zero accountability as to where it goes
in ukraine if it goes there at all well
you know my old boss dick army used to
say you can't be this wrong by accident
this
bad behavior
this destructive behavior it's not a
coincidence
people who are not looking out for the
american people are making the decisions
and it is time for a day of reckoning
november needs to come and every
american that uh discussion from those
people who are at the gas station
they're regular americans and those
people are going to show up and hold
people accountable
congressman when we have baby formula
which is something just so essential
we're america this is the american this
is the united states of america and
we're
scrounging around for baby food you know
i lived in the soviet union when i was a
student i said i'll never wait in line
for food again after waiting in line
just a student you know for little stuff
right this is the united states this is
what we're doing now
this is the failure of joe biden he's
failed black america he's failed white
america he's failed hispanic america why
because he just stumbles from crisis to
crisis there is no plan there is no
strategy he does not know what to do
this white house is a mess the agencies
are a mess and the democrats rather play
politics than actually get down to the
business of the american people
unfortunately folks this is the reality
of washington dc right now now rather
than fixing this issue that is really uh
striking at the heart of so many people
is about baby food
formula the biden administration is just
using doing the usual gas lighting
today president biden spoke with
retailers and manufacturers to calling
them to do more to help families
purchase infant formula what we are
seeing which is an enormous problem is
hoarding
people hoarding because they're fearful
and we are also have been also calling
on retailers to impose purchasing limits
to prevent the possibility of hoarding
because we know that that is an issue
why didn't we have hoarding during the
trump administration
this is remarkable every single one of
the terrible results that we see today
they can't be pandemic related this is
policy president biden has made it worse
everything he touches he has a reverse
midas touch he destroys thing it's not
gold it's a word that i can't say on tv
but they they keep thinking this is a
comms problem this is just to
communicate if they have a squishy yeah
if they have a better backdrop if they
have a better zoom call if they have
another celebrity come in and try to
sell it
but they don't
they don't want to admit i guess they
can't congressman this is a policy
problem and nancy pelosi uh has
basically by the way hinted that they're
going to spend more money
on on
on ukraine or covet excuse me that she
said more more could be on the way i
mean it's no end in sight for the
borrowing and printing as far as they're
concerned there's no there's no problem
that can't be solved without massive
borrowing this is the bernie sanders
plan on steroids and america is finally
seeing it it is a failure for our
country we have to reverse course and i
want to get to this new um pew poll out
today guys 88 percent of americans
believe that violent crime is either a
very big or a moderately big problem 88
percent and they say though this is just
a state problem this is a fox news
concern we've heard that
this this is bleeding into suburban
america but devastating urban america
the people who deserve at least the ones
who are struggling the most you know i
am sick and tired of this administration
standing up and trying to say how
they're looking out for black americans
how they're looking out for the little
guy how they're looking out for the
dispossessed the truth of the matter is
they have their core constituencies if
you're a defense contractor if you're a
climate crazy they've got you covered
but if you're everybody else too bad for
you there is a killing filled happening
in too many of the cities in america and
joe biden just goes out gets the milk
gets the cookies and takes a nap no
concern whatsoever and there's so much
happening with chesa bodine and san
francisco uh congressman donald's you
have lori lightfoot who believes she
should be reelected
her stellar record
yeah she's being challenged by some
other democrats but she she when she's
asked about this she's like i'm not
going to dignify your question about why
i should be re-elected i mean looking
down at a reporter who asked the
question this is how arrogant and out of
touch these people are but they've been
this way for a long time this is really
nothing new but i think now americans
with less money in their pocket they're
really focusing on it final word look i
think the failures that have happened
all across america democrats are going
to see this in november in spades it's
coming for lori lightfoot it's coming
for everybody else don't believe me go
ask those school board members out in
san francisco what happened to them and
they're all moving to florida to your
state congressman all right guys great
to see you both congressman horace hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else